You know in high school that friend
that you have that's cooler than you are
and they get all the attention
hello i think i'm jealous everyone pays attention
when i'm she-hulk colleagues she-hulk is a total
snack my family guys how much can you deadlift
a literal tongue when you're a hero size matters
series now streaming only on disney plus welcome
back everyone this will be my marvel she-hulk
episode 2 trailer video there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs and a bunch of cliffhangers that they
had to address from the end of episode one so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get them all we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just post
all your theories about what's going on on the
show careful for spoilers for episode one i know
there are a bunch of big questions from episode
one too i'll address those during the video
but they ended the last episode with her coming
back to her job after she got in her powers and
tried to go back to her regular life as a district
attorney prosecuting a big company who was being
defended by the law firm that she'll eventually
go to work for probably during episode 2 gkl and h
the name of the law firm is a reference to goodman
lieber kurzberg in holloway the actual name of the
law firm is a big easter egg for the founding of
marvel comics in real life the full name of the
law firm is goodman lieber kurtzberg and holloway
which is a reference to martin goodman he's the
original owner of the company that would become
marvel like he owned timely comics that would
eventually rename itself to atlas comics and
eventually renamed itself to marvel comics as
you know it today he's also the person who hired
a very young stan lee there are easter eggs for
him all over marvel comics martin goodman that is
marvel movies marvel disney plush shows like there
was just an easter egg that we spotted during loki
season 2 in an episode for goodman productions
who's an in-universe movie company making b-movies
in the 1970s who make this zaniak movie amongst
other movies which themselves are either based
on actual characters from real-life marvel
comics super meta like zaniak himself here as an
actual marvel character or they're fake movies
with titles that are references to real life
marvel movies or characters lieber is a reference
to stan lee's real name he was originally named
stanley lieber like that's still his legal name
but for professional purposes like way back
in the day he created the stan lee name
kurzberg is a reference to jack kirby that was
his original legal name when he was born he also
changed it later in life like stan lee did in
holloway isn't a big reference to a real life
person in marvel comics he's just another partner
at the law firm played by this actor here like
this is holloway during episode two he's probably
going to recruit jennifer walters she-hulk to work
for the firm superhero division and defend the
abomination is like her first real big case he
did the same thing in the comics basically one of
the big differences in the law firm in the comics
though is that it was in the new york city area
like around where daredevil practices law in new
york city in the mcu it's in the los angeles area
a lot of west coast avengers easter eggs happening
during the marvel phase 4 movies and disney plus
series and now marvel phase 5 too the other funny
easter egg about the law firm in the comics is
that in the comics they actually use in-universe
comics to help in their cases defend their clients
like if the hulk for instance got into trouble and
needed shield to defend him she would actually
use in-universe hulk comics to help defend him
super meta as well like in the background of
this lawyer's office in the law firm there's
a giant rack of actual marvel comics like there's
an actual company called marvel comics in the mcu
that creates comics based on these characters
the circle of easter eggs is now complete at
the beginning of the trailer it seems like her
before she actually joins the law firm like the
process of her being recruited for the law firm
you see her as jennifer walters but later in the
law firm walking around you actually see her in
she-hulk form walking around in her business suit
her voice over in the trailer sounds
like this big wish fulfillment situation
where she's basically getting all the things that
she always wanted when she was younger like it
makes it sound like she wasn't super popular
but now she is super popular because of what
happened in the recent trial and because of all
her sheila powers like you see her staring at her
phone and talking to jen about how she says that
she didn't want any of this and she's getting all
these likes on all of her posts and her profiles
as she hulk and it seems like through the course
of the episodes like not right away but eventually
she'll just roll with it she'll embrace that you
see that with all the jokes about her tinder dates
here too like later when she's in she-hulk form
actually trying to have a personal life and
date people she becomes more comfortable as
the she-hulk character than say like bruce
banner was as the hook at least initially
because as smart hulk as he explains he's better
able to use his powers to help people and he
doesn't cause nearly as much collateral damage so
it's kind of the same situation with her although
they do kind of tease that eventually she's going
to completely lose her control and we'll see her
full whole persona like they were very on the nose
with it during episode one when she's like i don't
think that i have an alter ego like oh yeah she
definitely has an alter ego they undercut a couple
different scenes from i think later episodes like
when she's in the dress at this big gala event
here you see what seems like a big attack happen
she has to hook out and save a bunch of people
the way they're playing that she seems really
comfortable as she-hulk wearing this dress so i
think that's from later episodes when she becomes
cooler with the idea of actually being she-hulk
like she becomes more comfortable in her new
body so to speak they have all this footage of
her inside the abominations group where it seems
like he's trying to help all these super villain
characters probably some superheroes too because
like she-hulk is here and she's sitting with them
but most of these characters are villains from
marvel comics a couple of these characters are
actually from daredevil and punisher comics too
talking about the netflix characters coming back
into the mcu but you can see in some of the other
trailers that he talks about being super zen now
like just like the hulk got super zen trying to
become the professor hulk version of his character
it sounds like the same thing happened with
abomination but the whole idea is that he might
actually be lying about it just pretending to
be super sent pretending to be good now so that
they will let him off her big thing is defending
him basically trying to get him out of prison
we saw a little bit of this during the shangshi
movie with wong in abomination it seems like wong
has been trying to help him actually become a good
person you also see a lot of scenes with wong here
inside the abomination cell talking to them while
they're going over the abominations case so that's
probably a big part of why he's on the show he's
also on the show because of the separate magician
character pretending to be another sorcerer they
don't explain exactly why he wants to sue him like
why is it necessary for him to sue him i think
the idea is that he wants to get him to stop
doing this and he can't do that legally unless he
goes to the court system they also clarified the
ghostwriter easter egg here too it's meant to be
a big ghost rider reference but it's meant to be
very tongue-in-cheek kind of funny joke about
ghost rider so i believe the idea is that this
character is pretending to be a magician like
he doesn't actually have magic or he has some
magical artifacts but doesn't know how to use them
properly because you do see this big battle scene
with them fighting inside this magic venue with
all these bats flying all over the place like wong
and she-hulk both going crazy in here but the
funny thing here like zoom in enhance it looks
like johnny blaze the name that the magician
is using is called doni blaze and the way the
writers explained this ghostwriter joke is that
this magician picked a stage name that would be
like the most attention-grabbing name he could
possibly put on anything so the minute you look
at it you think of ghost rider like he literally
wants people in universe to think of johnny blaze
you could look at that as them saying the ghost
writer does exist in the mcu a lot of what they
did in doctor strange too with the souls of the
damned in all these alternate hell dimensions that
they passed through just sort of canonized the
idea that those places exist so is then sort of
laying the groundwork to explain how it's possible
for ghost rider to exist as a character in the mcu
but we haven't actually seen like a johnny blaze
character inside a brand new marvel production yet
so this is about as close as we're
going to get i think short term
we might see the characters show up in like a
future related project like the blade franchise or
one of the other midnight suns related franchises
it does seem like they're kind of slowly putting
that team together in the background during all
the scenes where she's trying to date all these
people i don't know if any of these characters are
meant to be superheroes or super villains though
when she jokes about being able to deadlift a
literal ton that's actually an understatement
the whole idea with the hulk's power and it's
the same for she-hulk as well like technically
for story reasons there's a theoretical limit
but actually it's kind of unlimited if you
think about it it's just a question of them
getting mad enough to become strong enough
we keep making the world war hulk references we're
still kind of waiting for like that one thing to
make hulk so mad that he completely loses control
it might have something to do with that ship
from sakaar we're still kind of waiting about
that there was a big teaser for that during
episode one where hulk is like you know what
i'll have to check out to see what that was about
like they're literally saying oh yeah we're gonna
bring this back in a future episode so obviously
they will pay that off before the end of the
season she also breaks the fourth wall again
during this trailer during that big magic fight
scene i believe the actual title of the episode
is supposed to be whose show is this anyway
which is just a joke on the idea that there
are so many cameos and so many other big avengers
crossing over especially characters like daredevil
there's actually a trailer scene of her in
the car literally saying that like she looks
at camera breaking the fourth wall saying whose
show is this anyway i'm not sure which episode
daredevil is supposed to appear in or which case
he comes to work against her on because it sounds
like they're going to be going at each other
in court as matt murdock and jennifer walters
and then eventually at night as daredevil and
she-hulk and i also explained what happened
during daredevil season 3 and how the public still
doesn't know that matt murdock is daredevil like
his identity is still secret so like jennifer
walter she-hulk would not know that matt murdock
is also daredevil so i think the idea is they
spar with each other in court because a lot of
the show is them in different court cases but
then later they fight each other as superheroes
as vigilantes and she eventually finds out who
he really is like oh you're that guy from court
that i was going up against and then i believe
the idea is that throughout the series they'll
slowly build into more bigger background things
going on more avengers level stuff so that by the
end there'll be like a big teaser that will
lead into a big marvel movie of some kind
because that's the whole idea she's supposed to
be in avengers 5 kane dynasty avengers 6 secret
wars maybe some of the other bigger crossover
movies maybe even during daredevil born again like
it would be weird for daredevil to cameo on her
series and then for her to not cameo on daredevil
board again when that premieres but if there's
any big easter eggs that you spotted in the new
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments are there any big
questions you have about what's actually going on
on the show my full episode 2 video will post next
week after they release it big reminder too house
of the dragon episode one is coming this sunday
i'll be doing videos for that just like i did
for the original game of thrones series as well
obviously totally different but still really
cool that we get all these new episodes for
all these different series all at the same time
everyone click here for my full she-hulk episode
1 video in easter eggs and click here for my
brand new loki season 2 first look breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!